they were so full podcast welcome to the
were so full podcast what's our food
that's all we could afford to play
without getting sued so I can't even
tell you her name man cuz I don't know
[ __ ] cheese more sauce bro I can't
really mention comedian names anymore
kitty I go email him and tell him
exactly what I [ __ ] stickers a lot of
laptops bro
we listen to a podcast a lot of [ __ ]
my me Lance bro I don't leave us bro
a lot of people who get into a podcast
just to go piss off another comedian bro
bro let me tell you man if you're being
mentioned here in this podcast bro you
should be happy someone mentioned you
bro in front of 75,000 people do because
you could be out there bro [ __ ]
walking just walking down those [ __ ]
Echo Park they're like the Joker all
crazy and [ __ ] like Willie Barcena you
know tap eating [ __ ] right here we don't
you got a to Rodriguez right here the
our guest Mobile Rodriguez snuck in
again everybody burn right here what's
going on Dwayne the Muhammad Ali shut up
to the game of the roots to the fight
right yeah roots of life right it's okay
with Mesopotamia he gave everything for
free ever ever he just shows up and [ __ ]
takes all the weed from weed well they
got that weed guy named Zeno Zeno never
cheating with a little Papa door
chilling bro Sabeena lever I don't even
know man
so tell you man you could be a lever on
another level what player word I'll say
people's names doing that they go back
and tell them so I call points of
interface I'll set it [ __ ] pow nothing
but a bunch of keyboard warriors
nobody's gonna throw down
nobody he'll throw down bro people and I
know even if like a lot of these [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] like right they'll go
at you and go that tastes like and then
like don't like hate on you a little bit
or just say I don't think
funny and then you come and well [ __ ]
you my forget to follow me I was only
kidding I'm a big fan
oh really man or you come happen at that
[ __ ] big thing but the best cover of
the week out of Twitter was Joey COGO
Diaz I will repeat it right now I'll
just ask Audrey go
it was so joy dear this is the Peter man
I know you're gonna be in my town I want
you well get some free tickets what else
you want you want a steak dinner a lemon
will pick you up wait right there I'll
be right there who are straight up after
what else you want a [ __ ] steak oh
please
people can they support your comedy
career by getting in free all the time
oh my god you know brother let me tell
you brother you if you saw me at these
Latino events that are [ __ ] for free
you know or charity events you know
where the money going I don't know where
it's going but somewhere and then all
sudden you gotta pay you never is
supporting me [ __ ] yeah pay rent
on your ass you were supporting yourself
I did a whole video about it because I
was I'm passive aggressive sometimes
with the people that I know
no that's a razor cover attached to the
moon I'm I guess I'm bipolar
right there go I woke her over here I
want to support you and we'll come to
your show tonight can you put me on the
list
that's not support supported buying a
ticket to the show yeah I got four
tickets for yo show for me and my
parents with chicky the man I didn't
they fell because they're paying for a
two-drink minimum it goes to your zone I
know and I'm gonna get a [ __ ] there's
nothing free anymore man I don't think
you get to a movie for free even if you
did a whole comedy show sometimes for
like 10 bucks and you still want to ask
them me on the list yeah you shouldn't
be leaving your house if you can't buy a
$10 I'm gonna spend 10 bucks at
Starbucks man every time at if people if
people pay to go see Jose these [ __ ]
pupusas show bro you should be pay for
every other show room nobody complain
about that show no-nobody nobody
complain about [ __ ] going into
somebody backyard with a big-ass badass
stage internet show now explain that
show you got pretty much go to xavie
house his mom makes a bunch of tamales
and Musa Musa
only pakusa he changed it up a little
bit you know he's applying the man other
bits or two shows he shows and then you
pretty much have a backstage party with
the standup why no but yes
no don't pay you a plate for guess I'm
making a killing what there wasn't they
had I got Lisa harder 25 people
uh-huh yeah and a lot to media lot
haters lotta proposal being stored for a
buck right yeah there's a lot of people
there man and you know you know how to
give a cut to the club and to your mom
they make something or eat tamales right
mom's getting a deal Rudy ray boss but
I'll say you know they paid for that
pupusas event in there in worden or what
no I was hunting partner would like Paul
Silvi had a stage man with OCB and they
were selling alcohol their backyard
and everyone people five books yeah
you're on there am i but they were just
it was it was like great great patsick
oh oh they go to yelp review one star
Rodrigo about getting sick I was
watching that chuckle Chronicle article
show well anyways so the lady was
talking about this post did I tell you a
time when it is time we totally hot
buckling in motel a poor Kiera but put a
handful of thinking at home and I kid to
make a path of course as it didn't stab
yourself but also II don't mean for me
for that's how you know what restaurant
badass the guatita
a certain a time where I work a simple
guy you know he knows I'm a firm oh my
god never been sick
[Laughter]
imagine a baby came with approvals yeah
ratings no I wouldn't never have it a
woman Brad are you got a D for effort
yeah I can't say that in Spanish cuz
they'll judge me Latinos are judgmental
right yeah yeah not these four but the
ones I mean yes here was a chance we're
gonna see it yours either judgmental
there right there [ __ ] it on YouTube
speaking Klingon Rises uncle Joey made
her see that devil dog
I went Asami doctor oh it's that podcast
and I had a I ate one of those candies
by mistake I was hungry and I ended up
in the hospital
Wow don't belie I did you either start
or us it was a star and I'm you know I'm
hypoglycemic so I hadn't eaten you sure
wasn't want to Jodi receiving oh my my
blood sugar drops and it's over right so
I ate it and they were laughing right
and then I ended up I had to get two
shots without panic attacks and he was
like the habits of my wife
wow man you ready edible yeah I had one
time and it was bad what happened it was
as I put our daughter Jackie those air
than that party then the we party
although we didn't ever get invited yeah
is that the one yeah that's it yeah she
scared me man I never I don't smoke weed
I never smoke weed so that was the first
time I actually had like some kind of a
thing and I remember it I took it
because my leg was hurt and say just
take it and you'll relax I took I eat
the whole thing and nothing happened and
now we're later I remember I was washing
a table in my house and then I started
getting slower and slower and then my
wife was about to go to work it's like
exactly what we doing it what's wrong
wax I know my wife stayed off to work
she said you okay I'm like yeah but
where this seems to a heart attack
because she's a nurse you're beyond that
issue like she's like finally it's time
and then she just walked over
and I couldn't get up and I saw two
seasons of the Cobra that it was there
my brother was visiting and we bent
watched we didn't go anywhere he sat on
the couch and watched it I loved it and
we watched dance movies - that's our
thing we don't want to see Channing
Tatum cry we want to see him pop like
[Laughter]
bass oh you rat
yeah though your first edible in the
while Orion that was it I never know I
don't do edibles I can't I smoke weed
like I'm not gonna act like I like I can
smoke weed but the edibles I can't
that's for that's the hospital what
happened get too much sugar they said I
had to panic attacks I got two shots
that happens they said my heart was my
heart rate was like out of control so
they held me in for observation my son
called Joey like my father
and he was like what did you give my
mother and Joey thought it was so funny
because he was so respectful he was like
talking like to my dad he's like I'm so
sorry
he's a jolly rancher yeah and but he was
very like and he felt so bad he called
and said it's accident I was high for
two days oh yeah I didn't watch the
crown because I was spinning around in
circles saying I'm a happy girl I'm a
happy girl for real they said I stood in
the corner of my building and then
that's when my son was like she's gonna
lose her mind we better take good I
don't know how people can do that I
wasn't doing I couldn't move every now
and then I [ __ ] myself up on edible
cuz he says they do they they go to see
how high they can go with the milligram
yeah that's I can't do that I was like
you gotta trying to die they're sweating
that I was going back daughter shaped
also though yes the would say as far as
loss to belt okay yeah I'm likely are
you okay
his eyes are rolling and he's sweating
he's like I'm fine and I'm like no
they're just gonna explode one day in
the moon Alice yeah no I I had a panic
attack and then um I come my wife she's
like stop bringing me alone I'm at work
call your mom so I call my mom which is
the worst thing to do when you're an
edible bro cuz I realized I was calling
my mom so the first like moment the
Commons means I was like she say hello
and she goes I forgot I can't tell her I
was like get bustle and just quiet for
like 20 minutes and then she called my
wife and then they all called me and
everyone's to my house bro and did you
see me they're just sitting on the couch
couldn't move like and then that's when
a pack attack came and I said you know
what never again touching the [ __ ] no I
was I think was 10 milligrams
I was looking an intervention on it was
an intervention there's 10 milligrams
and my mom Murray and his Maddy why no
Ollie she came out of nowhere but that
the thing is I couldn't take is how
jittery I was for like about two days
[ __ ] jittery put your hand on at that
that that that we could be a hand model
bro well you gotta have your hands look
[ __ ] you like yeah I got you look below
the me bro these hands bro I should hit
Heather like [ __ ] like Halloween
ah what stood at the world is Halloween
costume you had
a wild one like I don't do the wild ones
I was a butterfly one time she's a sexy
Ruth Bader Ginsburg never like a cat
will you a fool
Erik Estrada no now and now I just uh
forgot the kids so we do like family
constantly we did ghostbusters last we
had last year yeah stuff like that but
I've never my mom wasn't gonna pass
those costumes with the little plastic
mask I would want to add those sulfur
kilos yeah we used to make our costumes
yeah man did you ever make a costume she
man she made me one your judge Ito from
the OJ Simpson trial
oh I was in seventh grade I was seven
yes by the EA T oh my want to be Batman
gonna be a judge
you look like Ito black fur to be oj it
was it was a graduation robe we got at
the thrift store like a black one and
then she pretty much put like eyeliner
make me look Asian
oh my god I went in there Asian face oh
my game Bobo can never run for office
cuz that takes you right up circulating
you know I know who he was nobody knew
he was but I didn't really know he can't
host the Oscars you look more like that
guy [ __ ] um that inspector guy from
the 60s out with that asian face which
was which was that his name buy someone
a movie Charlie Chan bro she go for him
this year yeah dressed up like the Hulk
bro with Lisa she was she Hoke but then
my [ __ ] green Reagan started peeling
off plus I have no muscles so she don't
like a jalapeno Elroy you were turning
back put it back on the way but oh yeah
dad I was at the Holly go to the West
Hollywood Christmas parade without the
although everybody goes yeah not just
gays but on the way out bro I saw a guy
dressed like venom and it was just a
regular African
American dude but he put all black
makeup on himself real shiny and a white
thing right here and he just had black
speedos on and it was just his whole
body
he was muscular perfect venom ever this
is way where's the camera the camera
right here over there this is to the
person who just say Ida Rodriguez yuck
III dicks that's how I feel about my
trolls in my haters they feed my soul
they make me happy on the internet at
his mom's house I named all my tacos
after my trolls and then I eat them whoa
that what you say you tweet a lot I do I
talk on [ __ ] you do you and that's so
much I know now I don't tweet it but
this is crazy
he's a troll on Twitter I bother you you
bother a lot of other people there's
some showrunners who you've made their
lives impossible I gotta call them out
yeah you get it
they all want they all want diversity
they're not doing it I don't know what
they all say they want diversity but
they don't do it so I'm out every every
time you go into a meeting we want to do
a Latino show we really want to tell the
Latino story who pops out of a wall and
then they're like we think that
Katherine Heigl should be the lead lady
for Grey's Anatomy bingo
oh yeah or the other might go like this
yeah but that guys never really been a
showrunner before we got through the
white guy in to supervise support and
help them out show you guys away
show how to save money who saw that Rudy
ray Moore boy waiting perfect massage oh
yeah bro do yourself huh that's every
Latino comic the whole story
Sarah bro and so then we put our tacos
job bro though we'd already pre was out
there bro primo any more guys who like
that the guy who wrote a kosher
Burroughs it named Oscar Coolio Oscar no
Toronto to Reno and break now nah nah
nah everybody wrote that movie man that
was the movie that I wasn't casted on
they had me go they had me read they had
me do all this [ __ ] they had me do
rewrites and they want a tenth time
recasting they never come
back so I'm glad I wasn't in that movie
hell no bro yeah bitesize bro was he
real erratic who's the winner for toast
of anarchy bro oh well that one man that
one has been like oh it's I'm sure be to
be my Dolomites might as well right
that's probably a bit player pretty sure
it'll be no bro how many CLP don't have
but wait I don't know you know been
there no all right
What's Up boo podcast people I don't set
out to other people who are from out of
town you know it's funny when you guys
when we used to have the call and people
will call in and ask those questions and
the people who are listening from like
England or Ireland they start talking
like yeah man and I really love in a
podcast where we love it boo
are you calling that phrase though
everybody when you when you hear that
you think about you that's your thing
you could put it on the show either my
name ain't ADA I would say Aida you know
how to say my name well you know you
know there's only a few comedians I can
speak Spanish to Allah that Allah team
bro
understand well that first time I saw
her like and I know they're like oh yeah
she she's cool she remembers me we were
doing the shorty one Oh Cameron hard or
JB smooth company central Wow and it was
all black fools dog whatever that they
cut they call it broke they were they
dug a fools I found they dug up fools
bro like from New York floor mark not to
say that we don't got no black food on
here but we got black ice there's a food
name they call smoke you say you know
him right smokey a smoke yeah from New
York and a guy named hot sauce from st.
Louis
doesn't a man in the back well you know
something I put no hot sauce in it
they asked me what time do you wanna do
the show I said who's on it they were
like
Food Stamp redbone it was like those
couple different let me write that's it
no I always hate those names don't like
would your mama call you because I don't
feel
Haqqani it is named little black ass
over here I got some Latino comedians
they got those names same thing I'm a
virgin by the speaker but redbone is
white is it really yeah bone he's white
he's away not even like Midwest
I know I know let the white car with red
bones no come no solo wins it was a West
Show or new your white doing New York
used to go by sauce and then he started
trying to go mainstream so he went back
to his real name Foster and we were like
wait a sec it is speaking of names we're
gonna have Alan Cummings on the show oh
no ma no Detroit Detroit expanding Helen
coming we got mobile Rodriguez over here
but wearing a billboard and [ __ ] yeah no
drinkie sponsored by everybody I gotta
lie bro I have a jacket bro and I have a
bunch of stuff too bro all right here I
have a flag and it's looking like a
Native American flag but it's all United
States and it has I speak Spanglish see
I'm sorry property on this jacket about
4 acres of mumbles jacket to light up
the back of left eye and claw yeah what
now bro everybody giving away this [ __ ]
for free
yeah every tell you [ __ ] you're like oh
my gosh it a restaurant for the first
time but you like the bagels well I'll
give you this bagels inside see what it
is you have a baby for free bro had a
great iced tea at this place
delicious iced tea people only put their
drinks with their home because they
can't afford the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
lucky but let's keep it real it was a
[ __ ] I came here to charge my
phone
children Lily keep my eyes out be hella
they got the best electricity my fax
machine I'm gonna at them oh you do 80%
off just tag it up did I start your get
kicked out of a viewership no more
[ __ ] plug it the whole [ __ ]
wedding star Joe look at the view gonna
tell ya man but my wedding had a 15 man
we got this fine arrangement from Julio
and I'm Figueroa and our key to is gonna
be done by we gotta eat those everybody
but if I a server Batman wait before
your wedding
are you gonna sell tickets Maggie
sobbing it's a show about her promoting
that show called yes forget to address
we're gonna have big dreams make sure
you get them tickets at brown paper bag
everything go part of the show yeah da
man for those of you who are trying to
get up find lodging you know we made a
deal with how to be in in Wilmington and
she's inviting everybody on TV by Rita
yes make sure you use chroma Stargell
Mary what happens with 90 day fiancé
DJ from Westmoreland he was taken at
Jamie Johnson veggie platter playing a
bro
Otis he rest in peace the Pops
crooked-ass feed dog coordinates happy
hit a bit about y'all I don't know I
can't do his poise but he was hit a bit
about um I bought like the older you get
the more crooked your feet get huh so
he's told about the man jacked up
happens when you put on women shoes
right Laura Tyson
nobody will tear comes out of my tooth
oh yeah a free Willie Barcena yeah
that's about here you gave was he was
gonna go to try yeah did that happen I
guess it did he's never really went back
on it I'm so long I'm so behind on the
Willie Barcena business okay Carlos
asked you want to be a part of the
fender I tell you why keep me out of his
house right no you didn't please oh we
wouldn't tell ya please berrigan's or by
god he had a show they're lazy me me me
and Rick the hair and and and really
were go to go Sacramento the day after
so he's like let's go to Willie's house
and then just you know work on material
we go to Willie sounds really invites me
he has a bonfire outside like always
bonfire righty huh right and you were
out there and I like the fire and I'm
like you know what I'm gonna go home cuz
I'm not gonna have time to make it back
to no walk he said you know what ah you
can sleep in my house you already have
your bag let's just go to Sacramento
tomorrow morning so that night we're
outside and I see his window flickering
in the bathroom in your window and he
looks out of my house that's my
everything I really Rick I'm gonna go to
your house right well I don't know if I
have room so in the [ __ ] man yeah
so I sleep in the bus station at that
night that morning I go from the bus
station Guri to the [ __ ] to the
airport I get to the airport and I see a
slant dog and I see I see Willy coming
towards me with those copy and a smile
and he goes and one we're gonna be more
positive man is that evil little armor
and hidden that when we get to
Sacramento his whole bits about ghosts a
whole set you wrote and inspired him
that night bro you're a ghost writer
egos man
yeah chamber right now what time he
actually instigated me to get fired from
a gig join join Medina hired me to go do
a mistake he hired me to go do the the
the punch line over there and no no the
comic strip and apostle bar read write
so he said listen you're gonna go over
there I'll give you 200 bucks but you
got to pay for your own way in the in
the in the Greyhound for guest spots or
I guess or just to open up for him to PD
bucks right since I know he's I'll give
you 200 bucks for the whole gig but you
got to get yourself just to hustle
calling the Greyhound is cheaper for you
so I go I'm like I'm not excited how is
he getting nowadays fitra money too
yeah I'm gonna give you a hundred hours
I gotta get down it was my first gig it
was my first you know Rose excited about
it I in mind before I mow continues let
me tell you something about me I have
never told the owner after every week
when we get paid he goes Filippo you
want the whole check or so you just pay
the guys normally I'm opposed to pay
everybody's don't open against theirs
and the feature gets that he was not man
you do what you got to pay them pay them
much opposed to pay them you know why
would you ask because something like
hairline it just keeps the whole thing
it gives them already bucks each [ __ ]
up the night no he said he gave me 200
bucks and he supposed that that also
include my you know he says I'll take
care of your room next door to the club
and then you gotta get you got to pay
for yourself to get to at bustles so
take the Greyhound I'm gonna fly so you
just take you know cool a day before so
I do the whole thing I'm excited about
it I tell this to Rick there and to
Willie Barcena cuz I was working on
something and really goes wow so you're
gonna do that to you
and now yeah I mean I'm it's grandma I'm
glad Joe is he's the first guy to give
me an opportunity so I'm very grateful
for this he's giving me a chance
well yeah but that's like [ __ ] perfect
victim and he's like he was telling that
yeah but will you happy
well I'm not happy I'm not really making
any money I'm gonna lose money so then
the next day he goes and tells Willie if
someone will complain about your gig
that you're giving him bro Oh Willie
told uh Joe you really told Joey yeah so
Joey gets pissed sends me the check says
hey man I think I found somebody else
for that gig and then sabotage that time
Joey was running the Laugh Factory yeah
so he I was I was like not booked for
like [ __ ] a whole year you never
caught those two fools up and go hey I'm
hanging out with Jose Lopez now he know
well you should explain yourself you
know and tell him you know you know
you're wrong bro I was like I'm not was
not complaining about any I told him
that but he didn't give me a chance he
did it behind my you know we didn't want
to talk to me about you confront me it
wasn't so like a year later at a
Christmas party The Laugh Factory told
me hey I just want to get things out of
the way you know the reason I canceled
you that day was because I heard you
weren't happy the way I was giving you
an opportunity and then it's funny after
we're all friends again he gave me the
following month another gig and it pasta
$150 hundred bucks I was grateful for
him but I just like the way they were
instigating against each other you know
I just try to pick a ham bro imagine if
your feet imagine oh you're a female
comic you wouldn't even be in this
conversation bro it'll just be like oh
never got booked there's no European a
situation with the headliner say you get
in my room 8:00 I was yeah tell us get
me will happen bro told me that no
weapon if you want to go on the road
with me you have to stay in my room and
I was like I'm good we're there Bretting
go right no
brandon t jackson was there like he
started laughing fat huh he got crazy no
he's on flat TV like saying like a wise
man yeah totally different brandon lost
his mind
yeah he started losing his mind well I
saw him on TMZ and he was like he was
like
you know there was a woman there and I'm
he was having beef with Katt Williams
and then that girl stopped him like put
his mouth on him just I say anything Wow
but that guy man like you know like you
used a comedy for the two hundred
teenage kid tour with Chapel
Marcia and then like what happened a
wine I don't know my mother she once I
told me that they gonna hire him to
write and I think that money worth going
crazy bro he blew up like there's like
he did the we know everybody does a
showcase on Tuesday nights and so he was
there I'm under for CAA or why a or or
for Haiti well a somebody please
somebody picked him up and put him in
that movie lottery ticket first and then
he went topic Thunder yeah he said that
he said that he said that the other day
on TMZ he was like I was just doing a
set and I got discovered that in and it
was at a comedy club it was CAA he says
wow you're not there project with him
and that moment I knew his mom when he
was like I'm doing his new clothing line
it's Jesus clothing line yeah but he was
showing us the clothing it was like long
long shirt from men with like the little
girl is that what do you think and I was
I with that blood stain one yeah I think
I didn't get booked a bar treats club
anymore what happened as they found out
that I wasn't a Republican and I was
like what gay yeah but he is yeah I know
but I was like I hit snot in the Sun was
the one that told me oh they found out a
year and ear and you like Ola
Laurie say enough Faisal no I didn't
talk about she had enough heart Obama
shirt on
no make the show no I didn't even talk
about that on stage cuz yeah he got mad
at another comedian angel Salazar the
great angel south oh yeah I guess he did
a show and El Paso pan out of his club
I don't understand he doesn't book me at
his club no more he says he's a
Republican at that Republican stands for
free enterprise well what happened to
one exactly in a huge supply exactly
wanted by the clubs oh no no listen that
Donald Trump effect is real this
affected me know how many club news they
know why they don't want more people
they don't want people talking about it
more nothing about but if you look at
the lineups it's all like a lot of those
clubs as a bunch of white guys very
Caucasian yeah yeah I see a straight how
I do yeah Goldman what's wrong
it's a pretty good man just to give you
know there's some stray hose in there
sometimes to keep I always love when
they post like we had a great line of
minutes all white faces Comedy Central
special he's a genius I do I do
I could call it but don't call it uh-huh
but do sell Tripoli show okay I mean the
only Mexicans there Tory neighbor Garcia
shows up at these are the we from the
weed Maps Samba SM has gotten a really a
vocal he's crazy right but um here's
here the podcast about quitting his
right I finally get here see right yeah
conspiracy theory oh yeah no I can see
that your spirit yours is he I will
never sign an organ donor card
hmm they sell that [ __ ] I think so so
George Karl is here bro you get a car I
said and they're looking for parts yeah
one of those they want mine bro I'm all
[ __ ] up I don't know you might have
some good parts in might have some good
you could advertise them on your Jack
just outlined them in Solem on patch him
on
so you started on me but were you from
though my New York Miami yeah
Miami Harley AHA liar No Hialeah my mom
lived in Hialeah for a little bit
damn not my style the hoodie built in
Miami Dolphins D no no no [ __ ] Marlins
yeah highly rate we know like you've
been there right you know the bill that
were the Martinez plant just notice they
didn't build a [ __ ] parking lot for
that day tomorrow it was I don't think
it was properly thought out it was not
because when I went to the game it was
like where's the parking why you gotta
look for a house they're gonna let you
know 85 bucks yeah talk about their
grass they do in the Orange Bowl
yeah that's a hustle in Miami is people
they ran out their lawns for people to
park in for events it's like it's been
going on for a long time well go but
they do $85 is right your parents
hustlers they sold deported so mom I
didn't grow up with my dad where'd he go
back to the Dominican Republic
you have the minikin have Republican I
know Republican but I got you know he
got deported three times l got an eagle
god I pass that what does that mean I
like these words man and I'm gonna be
saying [ __ ] about offending people no
it's beautiful it's good that were a
long table sometimes Manning would
haven't heard a long time made me laugh
God behold call me Connie who means what
oh you son of a [ __ ] that's a great
word I like that
oh dear Lord baby like dude
Thor you stupid idiot you know what I go
Puerto Ricans and Cubans they they have
backwards right bad it's bad like Beto
is a bad word in Puerto Rico and Cuba it
means bug mmm it means dick in two
Puerto Ricans what is beetle bicho means
dick and Puerto Rican yeah like a French
pastry I got a job at that in the Oh
Benny don't beat you and boy oh like
what I beat you yeah well Porter we
could say I'm boiled upon which means a
loaf of bread and boil means vagina and
kill
little boy wanna pop people even Cubans
car vagina papaya yeah it's so very
consolidated by yeah what about a grand
puta who's this lady so adorably our
door is no Puerto Ricans - for us it's a
whole other chingada yeah we heard that
one that sounds affect the Cubans curse
really well though mcCargo and Lara
contrac on you - Madhuri that's a big
city over there one over there male 2
word pose oh that's fighting words as
well as say that dick Oh Cory code or
email to Wyatt those are you're coming
soon come Amir da oh yeah poor Ricans
Cubans and Ximena can say that kill me
about Rob oh man - muerto I'm calling my
agent
oh we do we have a lot of dick we have
allowed me in for dick so so many public
oh yeah you stick to chilidog oh wow you
know that's not so weird cuz Puerto
Ricans either I win same deal we do octi
watching the Spanish movie and open le
Penelope Cruz and then his older woman
said to her again could the Bible's you
on you can America we don't bore you and
she was said the last time has been
years that she sucked the big I didn't
get our first proper so I [ __ ] do I used
to go out with his balance well in check
one time as she said my mother too well
and I said I was bald but turns out for
them its dick but I sent her a picture
of my [ __ ] balls know where I think
the ugliest word is the Cuban word it's
wewill bean guy Wow bad being guys gross
bingo that's Miami yes for mopping mama
laughing guys one thing Puerto Ricans is
hilarious I used to think it was a bomb
no Michael hey go hit by yeah
Oh
but it is I could go get it you know
yeah but that means they call him
probably a short version man yeah you
have to learn like you gotta adjust to
where you go yeah my wife got rosetta
stone also help it the Puerto Rican my
family good luck would you start it at
only my first comedy club that I ever
went up with was the Laugh Factory let's
you know NATO didn't know they'd have
Latino night then it was chocolate
sundaes I did first impression
three minutes first impression that's
but that's no hos you just go cold a
bomb like a set people up though like
just walk up then just start talking
what'd you say I was a legitimate did
you what you would have proved there by
said hmm make me laugh yeah it was
terrible I was bad and you know what it
was good cuz it made me say I want to do
this I wanna I wanna I want to not feel
this bad would you open with Oh with
your first base I don't remember that's
he knows that I really never over the
words of Bobby when you said yeah I'm
about to run somebody over on the way
home I was a comedy Union and I was
bombing and this guy in the back say get
her off the stage she's not black and I
was like oh I went to Russell Peters
house that day and he was like he DJ for
me because I was so I was so depressed I
bombed so bad they ran me out of the
club like I was like ends was like leave
now before the club lets up it's a game
that's funny cuz you're not real Porto
Rican
oh yeah cuz Puerto Ricans do the same
thing Mexicans do if you're not from the
island and you're not a real Puerto
Rican right and then if you don't speak
Spanish you're not a real purse we do
all that kind of thing no real corny oh
it's ridiculous that's crazy
not every chavvy is wrong yeah yeah that
was no frightening what writers impact
yeah those are the days I had to be
really careful though learning so what
happens over there
I do I would do well there but I had to
watch because a lot of there's a lot of
bad comedy going on in there right and
so you learn a lot of bad habits when
you do stand-up because I know about
that bad comedy and you're the funny
thing gonna be the start it's you know
you're really like with him it's the
world's bigger than the rule yes
see I'm gonna get that seat back then I
don't know man but of who were fool and
I think we were fooled with a good set
right there man yeah I would see it
that's exactly right then you see them
performing I believe they're bobbing
what happened I was like the Icehouse
effects they're called premature
millionaires the chancla joke everybody
was like oh I got a little trunk lotta
omok me a lot really say that brought
him too soon bro yeah the whole all
those the easy ones but then again that
was the audience there it was an easy
audience and then that what actor will
bring everybody bro and he'll never go
up he'll get it matter
yeah he was a soap opera actor was his
name he was Venezuela good-looking dude
he keeps a walk field in one time man
and did a set and then after the next
week
got a [ __ ] soap opera and it was done
Wow I'm doing this in the wrong ways but
that fool how do we take it down we came
back to do comedy and they put them up
with refried that [ __ ] about a
hundred and twenty-five people hours and
they keep telling him you were to go at
the end here to go up at the end nobody
got paid for those shows I was the crazy
thing about that I got 25 bucks one time
bro yeah I mean I used to bro I was like
I ask you tomorrow night for the chicks
what was the name of the little dwarf
that's a twin Caesar and uh yeah well
they do it bro what they would do is
they would they would want to money goes
and they will stand on top of that
little electrical meter they had in
front of the province just people would
be in line they'll be taking pictures
they would never go on stage they would
just be made fun of from you know one of
the comedians but I remember we used to
have that line go from all the way down
toward the cigar shop was it was a
people would be sent home but but uh
yeah they put anybody up that brought 20
people first
one of the times I was on stage chef
Garcia waited for me to get offstage
room row and then he said come here let
me talk to backpack
and then outside he was like I don't I
don't do this often so if I'm talking to
you is because I think you're funny so
listen to me listen right now I'm gonna
tell you a couple of things and I don't
want you to say anything I just want you
to listen and then he gave me these like
rules of comedy by DVD burner got that
talked to and then I'm sorry I will go
to his club like in the Corpus Christi
and his parent with his parents heard of
him telling me that would have had them
in a chokehold II know you were a show
at the latter improv we offer Tobey
Hicks and Dave Chappelle just went up
and nobody went up I mean it happens all
the time cuz I know you were in a show
and I don't know if you were the host or
Richard beer with a hose but Dave
Chappelle showed up and he'll put a do
like ten minutes I'm gonna just do ten
put him doing the whole show like nobody
went up I'm going home I know that joke
bed upstairs nobody does five minutes
ever they're gonna do five and five no
yeah but they TMZ came to the Improv and
then Dave Chappelle got all these people
to follow TMZ and then they went to TMZ
and harassed the TMZ people that's
awesome he did that from The Improv hold
your fun shows man but I remember
watching her and everybody that she was
with my pair comedians grin when I
started doing comedy I'd always go and I
was that dude that would just talk you
know certain marks try to sneak into it
was going on but I remember following
all you guys going to whoa you're dating
a girl doing comedy huh yeah it was
horrible man why is it go to comedy Oh
big the other thing no because because
she was a point he was she was just
trying to do it because you're using her
she was saying yeah she was saying like
what I mean her she would say if you're
doing it then it's probably the easiest
things to do she's like so when I try it
out I mean people are laughing at you
and I'm
bet I mean no offense babe but I'm
better looking than you are he died she
told me that other actual work she
thought was I ain't care cuz you know
she was doing your top you saying that
those good top me saying it's those fine
oh wow yeah and then and then we started
her act her act was mostly about being a
fat guy
I remember their only saw I was always
cry in the back of the [ __ ] room
right we thought mobile yeah she never
you know why don't kill Justin just
don't say it's me
mi everybody knows though she said babe
can you put my website did you write
those jokes no I
she wrote her own what did she whoa no
no she she went to school she went to a
class took that Icehouse class Judy
brown she told you because you're doing
it she thought you could do it and your
daughter's gonna come to you to teacher
she goes to take a class to class right
you gonna hurt their feelings
nobody was [ __ ] nobody whole day this
girl and then one time she sound like
we're at a strong s people bombing so
maybe I should do Carmen if they're
maybe not make her freely right there
boy that's a bro and then she goes out
what would you tell me that because
you're not funny it goes and I could see
that funny but it's like be like if I'm
telling you now funny maybe you should
try it then yeah cuz I'm telling you or
not you can't take it you know you never
really know many people told me oh
they're funny yeah a million really I
love you too no not funny Oh like people
you know yeah was the first ones really
fat ass out of my house but mom mostly
they support me but nobody from my
harira goes to my shows yes
mother don't knock the versatile I
I should never happen my mom doesn't
even understand comedy like that she's
deported right who does she think she is
JLo and I'm like I'm a comedian but your
show instead
are you tags no my mom was on stage and
I was talking about how she's hit us
when we were little and she stood up and
took a bow that's you so I was like
don't embolden her and only at the end
of the show she got an applause break
when I start doing stand-up comedy
I guess I'm my no doing stand-up comedy
but never been on anything back then and
I remember I guess my father he always
want to be on TV - that's what started
getting involved wrong I'm your manager
you know he 32 windows little shows like
Hello his who says he's in borås yeah
and you have a show called uh-oh that
was like the people score but in a
Spanish station yeah yeah where's the
barrio bro my dad got in the show who
were hitting me up I see your terror
team right now bro is that really your
brother I did the chorus honest me too I
said buscando Wow no I did I said no
secret as soon as they give me 200 100
bucks in 300 if you kiss somebody on the
show what did you do fool I made it to
the end it was me and his other girl and
then they told me that they were gonna
go with the other girl because the girl
was gonna kiss the guy yeah I think I
was with one gotta see her with Elvis so
what did he wear drool
I don't think he would he pass through
he wasn't even have enough charisma
I would call you the producer no
charisma to be on the camera like Al
Pacino you have it but not no no they
told me one have enough charisma to be
on the show but we're comedians I did
the other one too though I did the
cheaters one to vanish
yeah did the cheaters on in Spanish she
said oh oh and I got to beat up my show
called Busan Oh square miles which one
the cheater was no ice on 60 released
when they went in and they cut her
husband an orgy it was a bunch of ak-47s
Mardy and a bag of coke and a bunch of
fake sicarios bro and then she's
slapping the coke everywhere it's all
over his face yeah they had to put her
in store more than the actual cheated
show episode arc was but yeah what
happened who would you play the cheetah
the cheetah the cheetah you and I got to
beat my husband's ass and it was so
how'd that fool of would be like well
that summer you were dead or held oh no
it was a Manhattan but for me it was
this sort of guy and he was in a motel
in Manhattan Beach and we broke into the
hotel room and there's such instigators
and that the lady was like know about
something and I'm like wait you haven't
mother feel me I'm just saying it now
cuz I know at some point it's gonna
resurface Rito I'd applaud Annie Tony
the wedding
the wedding singer bro huh we went to
[ __ ] out New York to shoot a pilot in
the coldest right like a week before
Thanksgiving so it was cold at [ __ ] huh
so every day we would get up and then
somebody would drive us to New Jersey
bro to film this [ __ ] so like how she
got to hang around with all the wedding
people bro she got to hang around with
the the [ __ ] the bride the bride and
though and the prize mates and the mom
broke a Minik inside no it was the
dominican sign yeah yeah and I got to
hang and go wrong with the boat with
them with the guys the robbery came
probably which is the two parlor
remember he's so hungry bro he cheated
right before I almost called it off her
the day before the wedding bro no two
days before like we are just feeling
wrapping everything bro they were just
chilling and somehow it was that way
it was that neighbor chip we saw ha I
know someone or a girl
remember he's friends with the her
brother you know someone yeah part of
the water cycle
Wow but dude it was drama bro those he
was on a motorcycle with another chick
and knows those chicks homegirls chase
down fluid in the car and he was trying
to run from them in a [ __ ] motorcycle
all across New Jersey to the Bronx
everywhere I was almost off so didn't
they tell you to go talk to him and I
had to go talk to her I didn't know
brought a bag on them without evil
reality show and in a called abroad I
see what's gonna happen
she told it for to this is what I
happened man he's gonna go there to talk
to the [ __ ] all the mom
the mob both bars are gonna go talk to
her say man how much money they put it
to this thing that's right
and they got happen to Lisa I started to
you know the momment or the mom would
never talk to her toner you know how
much money they'll put into this Letty
was care about her heart not care about
nothing [ __ ] happened today cake tasting
remember it was great it was good as
[ __ ] cakes oh god bless him after
story we don't know do a reunion show
we were the we're there at the with the
actual wedding bro that tux the reality
show should have been behind the scenes
of the production remember cuz they that
the whole network just went away
remember yeah it was on CTV CTV and then
it became what was it a pneumo Nouveau
we did it for Nouveau Nouveau yeah
confused and now you see TV arms way
back I don't know everybody had a
contract with that no I don't deal with
them I deal with CTV and then I turned
to new one nobody told me so I guess I
lost the CTV do everybody the hello
there is done right because I know that
just did a special special you were
young we were on that show yeah and so
that's no I don't know one we were all
on there yeah no but some of the special
so he did what everyone
Angela but I did one but they won Jean
they were saying oh I know Gabriel
Gabriel they tried to get gave to do one
a game ended up producing yeah he'd put
his name on there were two uh yeah and
for nouveau oh yeah I don't have the box
set of of Latino 101 I just pick it up
microbe life worth pancreatic cancer bro
yeah I dunno I did a fundraiser for him
but November six seven at the haha cafe
and it's gonna be here in the podcast on
the Wednesday before the show and talk
about that guy sir he has [ __ ]
next Wednesday he was a kid locusts no
no you were you at the black shows no
wasn't doing comedy and I'm not gonna
listen not start I start a year I told
you that drew let's go miss daddy I did
last comics fan you are the black people
who came and gave me opportunities
Latinos never extended opportunities it
was Wanda Sykes that
Last Comic Standing Tiffany how does
that produce my special it was Shaq
Shaquille O'Neal who put me on Showtime
Latinos would be you know actually the
main condoms would be like she's not
Mexican or you know if we have so much
division amongst ourselves
oh yeah man they really looked out like
we did that show together that was Kevin
Hart like that was no skimming heart
yeah he hosted it was the last that was
comic view public view yeah that man I
bombed really bad but I have only been
doing stand-up for 13 days but there
were people who have been better to soon
roll yeah I was too soon there were
people who have been doing a poster no I
didn't know were there when I when there
were people you saw and they've been
doing stand-up for years that were
bombing because the audiences were all
cool and then something one of the
comedians fell down walking down yeah
because you had to walk just walk up
these stairs bro [ __ ] pops the stairs
were on the stage yeah now when you come
and you walked on the stairs and then of
the the block on a Tuesday
I almost there were bright bro like
silver look a free free Willie Barcena
so I'll be doing comedy there now 11
years 11 years right hustling yes either
watch yada hush to do open mic yes of
course when I got to work no material
out so you're gonna take time over to
open for you when I was at Vegas
he lived the bigger though right yeah I
thought he's in Arizona
no no he's he's been a guest on the
podcast he's done that short I saw at
the [ __ ] hour hundreds episode show
with gene pompa
and his little hat I haven't seen him in
a long time either you're up somewhere
with a wine you know Audrina amigo at
the improv and they're leaving but I
going up
how you do it man
well you'll be doing long enough they
will you sit down anywhere oh yeah you
are a part of the show I mean yeah
uh-huh
give me the prime rib and rings and it
just takes off
sike little tip it's a great yeah
see I never will your imagine having a
steak my daughter
what's up fool so you go to auditions
yeah I do I don't do well at auditions
well you don't like acting I do I just
don't know I think a lot of I forget I'm
tall so a lot of the shows are with
little people right smaller people so
I'm always thinking like I was 510 511
right I can't close the book in this TV
show and then the producer call my agent
it was like we have a really short cast
you know so I haven't developed a
complex about it but I do I did a little
go on these sets and you're like wow
these people look huge on television you
go with her boy but like it was
ex-girlfriend bald little fellow woman
of LA tallest not every audition but a
lot of them yeah especially how tall are
you 510
okay that was funny when they call all
the comedian's though right so like I
was on an audition for a TV show for ABC
so it was me like Gina was there but
Loni love was there like I was like oh
they don't know what they want you never
know like it was a whole variety of
everybody so but I audition I take
classes and I got a coats oh yeah
directing cuz every week where you go
with a Deborah Lyman lemon right there
on by that supermarket was it called
that's a plug right there did you see
that supposed to be charging for that
job because the wrong name was still
plugged by Joseph whether by Gelson's
yeah
yeah I've been going there for years
nice that book was it met with her
that's good man
I thought Pat I did this political show
a couple of months ago my Pat was was
one of the people running in and she's
booking right now on the dinner laughs
at the Void San Antonio which about day
they called you yet no well you call
them they called you I got a call
oh that's a they're just they're asking
about certain dates but they don't have
no details that's that bad I find that
sketchy you know what man was the first
year they booked it when they booked it
there we had everything planned out
there we had was show they're gonna do
who was gonna be there sponsors and
everything bro they said $200 not gonna
get myself down there why do they they
don't know who to call man oh like you
gotta go out there man like do it like
you did 20 years ago go for the young
comics you know the people who are out
there who are funny they have six
minutes of funny [ __ ] you know could
those other people gonna tell you yes
everybody else gonna tell you give me oh
man
baby [ __ ] take the ground now oh
what's that called the Latino laughing
first of all I did in 1996 those my know
my claim to fame bro yeah so this day I
took a checks whenever they sell that
show again to Europe or another country
again look $300 from that they tape it
Hillary said it over and over and they
brought me in a nouveau cuz I wanted to
do a comedy you know yeah and they were
like hey you're gonna host this show
like cool and it was just me watching
old clips of Latino laughs as well I saw
you like real young I was like and some
of the bits have no hair off some of the
[ __ ] was were bad because they were
like oh you ever get that VHS tape and I
was like no one's gonna understand this
yeah what are we doing here because they
were dated yeah because they don't want
it they don't want to spend money on
booking a new show so they're like so
you'll just throw it to the clips and I
was like okay what do you ever think
sometimes how long you've been doing
stand-up 23 years 22 so you everything
like about all the people that are the
soldiers that fell along the way that
you like to have that person is a nurse
now or it up you know like all the
people cuz I just thought about why I'm
not retiring Wong Kar
I'm just saying I haven't seen them in
so long did you ever think about all the
people that were around when you started
stand-up and you're like no Last Man
Standing
I don't I don't really remember anybody
who quit I think I saw city [ __ ]
some people should quit I see people
like put up let me see I saw a comedian
that I started with be the black comic
and I saw him delivering a FedEx box
from my house everywhere what happened
he goes oh man I've only had this job
man and the bagel but then he know he
had kids divorce or that [ __ ] me and
they were really colorful green eyes or
screws or bones one of the names oh I
ran into a guy that the comedy was that
with that with that community from Long
Beach Tamara and Marty Moreno back he
the Long Beach guy and he told me this
crazy ass story about a comedian that we
had on our show cuz he was a manager at
bars with man what's a man the
[ __ ] comes up to me he goes yo
man you do comedy yeah but once in a
while [ __ ] that comedy right now man but
we'll turn to that armored truck here Oh
what the [ __ ] that's awesome yeah the
month was make up that's crazy so you
know doing stand-up comedy I do what you
like about it
performing know happy times bro baby
we said the events performing that's the
best part about that about yeah
everything else might ain't gonna be all
happy no politics is [ __ ]
yeah but I love it though I love if if I
could deal with just doing this you'll
be all right because you're 11 years
that part the politics that goes away by
the time you're doing 14 you realize you
know that what was I thinking about like
that you know what cuz you know you know
you thinking about like 11 years
you don't need policy that you have is
it like it's you're dealing with it now
but but when you were doing 7 or 6 you
never do it because you're not at that
level but now you're at this level you
deal with there you go okay you feel
like [ __ ] why this [ __ ]
like eight I've been doing the 11 but
once you hit like the 15 mark or 14 you
pretty much seen a lot of [ __ ] and
you're like you're gliding man you're
getting all the gigs in book you know
you know that you don't know if I'm
headlining I'm gonna just bring this
girl with me because she's cool and she
don't believe that do my material and
she says to herself we're gonna have fun
look you know what Louie CK told me that
too he was like when I saw him in New
York and he said this before he don't
know when is wrong no I'm not his time
but he said he said once you when you
hit the 15 year mark he said it changes
but he said the same thing me and
Marcelo were in DC together last weekend
because we were working two different
clubs she was at the at the [ __ ]
giraffe house you were right we're at DC
how many lost that's Newland yes
comedy laughed and then they have the
[ __ ] giraffe house in Arlington and
they have a draft house in DC and
they're DC Emperor for clubs so there's
no way you been already I've been a
draft house and I've been a man which
was relevant DC yeah just all right no
and the Arlington one but I haven't done
the improv war loft they compete right
yes I did a guest spot at the improv
when Michael yo that was it I'm a booked
I look I really enjoyed the comedy
laughter yeah the audiences were great
and they came out you don't know that
the Denver Comedy Works no Kyle Osaka
teriyaki I was just thinking about that
cuz I used to do the improv and then
they stop booking me you were headlining
yeah are you doing it that way though
okay now the manager that oh you were
doing it with a guy named a little big
little [ __ ] do what to go to a store
Derek or some [ __ ] there
no it was Philip the tall black guy
oh yeah he's good I was yeah the NBA
player he got me tickets for the theme
park when I was there the last time I
went to the theme park yeah I want to do
comedy works though Joey always tells me
that's the club they do yeah I'm a
lovely place when you get there man they
do the same real rotation that they've
been doing in the 80s and they don't
realize that the rate of that rotation
not were helping this club anymore
a man would say man you're gonna put me
in a rock station I might be a little
rock star but your fans yeah yeah put me
the hip-hop bro yeah put me in the
oldest book duty station the Spanish
station yeah yeah and they don't that's
true though I did some we I went to do
radio and I think it was Michigan and I
was like man this is this is so dated
just like a radio station radio station
it was a morning show and the one guy
listen man I do five characters when I
start doing are you pretending that
you're talking to five different people
I said what's his name what's that
dude's name from the one from the
Mexican guy that plays a chick who plays
for the rusty mascot yeah that guy is
deep bro you gotta do that show anybody
gets a chance to promote any show ever
anywhere do that is right for that guy
man
I was on a soil so well for us yeah I
did his show and broke that [ __ ]
somebody I haven't been to this part of
Mexico's in 1982 yeah some of the
[ __ ] some and that hurt me insomnia
night show he [ __ ] emailed me and
we're here in Tewksbury I need two
apostles and I said yeah Oh what that
weighs like yeah billions in you were
little he look didn't let her eyes I
know your whole family probably stop
[ __ ] it shows great yeah I wrote for
that dude for all those characters by
angle was different it was I thought it
was odd different people now when I show
up now for the ragging room I wore these
people at and he's like it's me that's a
true Latino we got a budget for work I
know Mike Rowe
I watch every rotation where the white
dude there was doing a black lathe voice
Oh like I was talking I was talking and
then she was like Carla yeah
Filipe it was all excited with laquanda
perfect bro you know I did I did the
Cabo Comedy Festival the last year oh
yeah but let me tell you though I was
that [ __ ] though the cabo was great the
Cata festival was now heard about with
that but I was one of the judges ran
that Cisco Richard beer no it was some
guy named I don't know his name but I
powered the Spanish part and I judged
the Spanish comedians and let me tell
you I want to find this girl there was
this blind girl who was meghana and a
fine young one of the funniest comedians
I ever saw in my life she made me cry
laughing she was so funny that was my
highlight of the festival and uh also I
looked up for see a guy pollito
know she was and she was better than all
the other comedians that were in there
she was a real comedian she had jokes
you have shows coming up this week I'm
going to New York on Monday Eric and I
are your comedy what New York Comedy
Festival I'm doing my own show on Friday
November 9th at 8:30 at the stand and
I'm doing your show November 5th at the
Comedy Cellar
Village Underground Oh promoting my
special super white first you gotta hit
up on my friend over there Latino
comedian he live from the he's from the
Bronx with love right
funny Latino and yet he go look up a lot
of those shows you know in the Bronx
with a lot of Puerto Ricans
what's his name Roman Suarez Oh funny
Latino he always hate to be bored with
her just mention you're gonna be there
and now for her bring up people to your
show okay yeah and you know sad right
now because I'm which um wasn't you
broke up with him was her name Paula
Abdul No
Lisa Nicole J I love these that's my
friends yes she wants to kill earth to
her Shore and just don't mention Roman
no much only with that what's in her
concert here I went with Stevie B and
author what's your Instagram funny
either AIT a and check out my Netflix
special right now I'm a so three on
three
yes episode 3 what are they ready on
Netflix Tiffany Haddish produced it make
sure you watch it what's your Twitter
funny I about AI da was your Twitter
fool mama Rodriguez just do it but I
paranormal I am and we had a great
episode last last week we hadn't reached
Shore less we should have have Willie
but that's all about that's out of the
club muumuu okay so mean well so
everything what's going on so this
Friday if you're watching live my
special drops HBO Latino gonna be
available HBO HBO now I should be on
demand call super white so please watch
and then just follow me online Eric
Rivera comedy well Julie you're a
Spanish show coming up right with Marty
Moran on a budget or the food's gonna be
an English show and that's it all that
the Paramount November 20th November 12
V little jokes in English in Riverside
at the lightboard Center a PM Yemen oh
damn Momo how many people come up to you
bro have become a trans in its
collaborate but come on no pencil do
many times many times many times what oh
yeah hold on people I'm gonna be a San
Diego this Saturday November 2nd the
humphreys by the bay West Jordan Utah
Utah wise guys color Samoans call the
Mormons November 8 and 9 but that's what
California November 15 at the Gallo
center what we got Manny Maldonado on
that show let's see hopefully see how
many people in family really show up
don't actually pay okay but that's to
California a guru was that worry always
says it's okay but so so fuller in
Mexico and I put W I thought what could
be do that time we go to vacation bro he
does yeah you have time now you ever
love occasion no I was just talking
about that the other day I'm you know
they're in sandals kind of play with
sandals but you know what bro of yeah I
would say if you have the time and the
money to go on vacation right now I
won't say go now because if you get
popular you need an eating outside of go
anywhere
yeah you'd be doing interviews he was
doing podcast we're doing paranormal
activity I'll go five dates a vacation
see that she'd want to comedy with you
bro who your ex-girlfriend no that's not
vacation though cuz I went to Aruba to
do stand-up Aruba and every night I
would have to go do the show and that's
it by the time the show was over
everything was yeah that's true so it's
like I'm also I'm a being Magoo B's
Magoo Baltimore Baltimore timonium yes
timonium before no it's great though the
owner he's to be in the army he's a real
nice guy and he'll take it pretty much
anywhere
the child is small man but it's a
college town so yeah
yeah I'll be there the weekend of
Thanksgiving but 29 that's what they
give women yeah man everybody starts man
cuz dumb we're not whatever when I was
dumb when I wanted to come and standing
flip your book when no more day weekend
alright what the July Labor Day
Halloween the Wednesday before
Thanksgiving and Friday Saturday after
that yeah January's jacket they always
give me Valentine's Day
anytime you get those days you like so
we repress what Thanksgiving blues you
just show up
no let's make fun of Portland man but
that Club they actually booked me mmm
and brought me out Thanksgiving weekend
and have fun helium no no I'm Harvey
Harvey I shut up to the owner hopeless
to alive
dan : I know you were sick
Wow Bakersfield California member 16 at
the Park Theatre Napa California
November 22nd at Uptown Theater Seattle
Washington November 23rd at the Neptune
theatre Spokane Washington November 24th
at the Bing Crosby Theatre Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania November 29th December 1st
at the brand-new Pittsburgh improv
Spanish shows and tone shows when I turn
is paniolo noviembre and MMP mellow
noviembre my weapon Italian Boyle
Heights sold out I didn't wanna tell you
that show so it sold out November 13
Tijuana myheco
at the Antigua but they got there my pal
hopefully they'll fix that [ __ ] sink
cuz man I remember I came out of the
shirt
wash my face you know and I put soap in
my hand I looked around the water didn't
come out and then go and I looked around
and there was like a bucket with warm
water ready for me I feel like a king
November 17 Pasadena California at the
Ice House stage two Spanish Oh remember
twenty nine still more California gosh I
thought is where the tortillas are warm
and the people who have been drinking
since 5:00 p.m.
sounds fine another show coming up
that's it also for your listeners Marin
Latino night back to laugh at the
beginning crying so cool everything is
just why are they [ __ ] them what's
his name
Joey rocky over here bro everybody here
left it all night at the Laugh Factory
the next show next year was November 19
November 19 okay let me tell you that if
you say if you say what's up full
podcast at the door where the [ __ ] is
Eric or just say Eric on the wall so
full podcast or just say Eric Rivera was
so full podcast if you are listener if
you want to [ __ ] watch Latino life
bro and support this show man we're
gonna bring that [ __ ] back more
Rodriguez pass out flyers you know how
I'll go ahead and out like we used to do
we did the first one I was on it we had
we're trying to build it that way the
club doesn't get rid of it
we used to work and do it we used to
make us go to the Laker games it was
under uh huh
Jia massaging makers were sure to say
Laugh Factory we passing out those free
tickets bro ah maybe I'm in trouble I
saw I gotta buy a space I'm almost
jagged that's all you people
sorry little free tickets right there
man and because once the crowd is
starting big sorry my stepmothers gonna
show up and just put a leg up it's are
charging people shouted a kook man he's
all in love right now yeah she's a great
singer yeah I just want him to be happy
man because they stole 20 million
dollars from him so if he's that to date
anybody just to be happy over him huh
they give him and it was this family who
did you see you mess up on Jimmy Kimmel
no no John Farrell whatever the name is
John McCann on Channel NBC tonight show
Jimmy Fallon yeah you heard a show
talking about that John McCain if you
thought [ __ ] that please I don't
watch it anyway so he was telling my
lady
oh yeah man because when my special came
out my daughter was my wife wasn't even
born and then he said that have you seen
me at preschools it was because I was
looking for my wife that's freaking
creepy Piatt my right for that agree but
he said when I think about how great she
is and how she came into my life and
where she's been all my life and then I
realized that for the first 28 years of
my life she didn't exist
Huggies brought to you by hug mouse
great smart good at the dot and the
mother of a daughter that means were so
[ __ ] a double G what are you gonna
have your own podcast I just talk a lot
of [ __ ] for one hour and get other
Latinas political activist all on your
side starting a year you can't come back
you got a way I gonna work if you get an
opposite of you and you go up and set up
with needs he's clean
that's a good point he went to college I
read a lot of books on audible I went
through six pitches you already take
that he hot curls his hair doing the
college right back later you emerge away
NFL player right out with the college oh
the name twenty d'Orsay no I don't say
his name right
no my son doesn't play my son is a
director yeah he graduated from school
he didn't want to play sports he got
scholarships and stuff well you don't
like he like eight you don't like Asian
women right like you knew that no I was
like how did you how did you know he
played for the Chargers no cuz you know
they always used to say it was funny
because when he played for the Chargers
they would say just watching cuz the
Filipino women are very aggressive maybe
we had to cover this you one time they
would tell them that he said he left her
fur up for AI easy woman no he did it he
left you for a woman that made his
Jersey she I don't like to say I left
him cuz I think we did left each other
you grew old man you can watch it on say
Kratos you use a low feeling force to
create those to bring out the character
since memory there was no that was I was
dating a cheater right I was dating my
ex-boyfriend it the art is known as the
cheater and food like a cheater like I
know like oh really bad I don't know
people have cheated and or
I know people cheated in size but it
went so like like straight up like I
know guys who cheat who cheat like but
they like they just they hide it but the
people would cheat bro don't give a [ __ ]
like those tough flirting with the way
to Ron oh yeah he hit it he was like
MacGyver like he half he was dating four
people at the same time and everybody
thought they were his girlfriend Wow he
was will do such a thing
[Laughter]
you gotta know he was seeing better
inside I better learn a little young
white Carmen hey following you huh or
hate working with you just drop you're
just wrong woman
you're Charlie gonna [ __ ] [ __ ]
somebody up with comedy and physical but
you know it's a young comic you know
Latinos are not afraid bro they will go
up everywhere I want to bring up the top
ten comedians I never believe that [ __ ]
because you know what they don't they do
the easy rooms yeah you know they do a
cater room bro but they give up cake at
the end of the show yeah and if you
[ __ ] bomb there's a little room when
everybody gives you a hug I just stand
up in bellflower with a promoter had a
pit bull chained to the inside the club
bottoms up right the guy that they had
they have one of those flashlights that
they put up with no for the car that was
your light and you run some blood life
yeah yeah a floodlight how's your stage
light and then you were by the entrance
so when they everybody who walked into
the bar you walked right through you
performing on stage and they were
walking out talking loud and see and
that people would look at you like yeah
I wish if you bomb they never told
people there was stand-up that night I
did a guy who does all the fundraisers
always in Whittier Robert yeah I do here
I did all about the room and the guy who
big was a drug dealer and now he's a
pastor and he used to have all these
rooms no Chris no but I did all those
rooms I was never scared to go
I think we met that's what we met yeah
she got that 20 guantes what was the
name of that was the name of that place
Rivera I did all those rooms I was never
scared to going you and the comedy Union
I did the the though we selves Club in
Compton where they give you they throw
money on the stage the family room I did
I will go all over those places I was
never scared to go cause it's easy to go
up at the at the improv when or the
Laugh Factory or the ice house when I
hear about this white Carmen he was
tremendous the genius unbelievable where
I wanted a quick comedy after I seen
where but where were these crowds he
destroyed a heckler what's heckler oh I
saw with him antagonizing that guy yeah
a real heckler one of us is Donald [ __ ]
you [ __ ] make me laugh that's
right I was up there teachers jacket and
puts it on yes all right listen I'm not
gonna say the name of the comedian when
I was in San Diego and the comedian was
hosting the show about you thank you
wasn't doing well
this woman Benji heckling him and he was
lying you think you could do this she
said yeah he said well come up here and
do it and she went on stage and walked
out the club she rubbers this comedian
is like he had the best bit worst luck
with me because he's the bully me when I
started stand-up and then I was always
one day he was in that Club it was a
Jamie Club Jamie
Masada's Club in yeah someone someone
well so he was going up last I would you
know you go up first you get a lot less
money the people that are a yeah he was
like man Frazier laugh because that's
what I do I'm a headline right Tori rock
no no there I went to eat and when I
came back he was fighting with the
audience because they were doing the
electric slide
that was one of the toughest faster
worse someone's getting booed through
that room people would go just for the
party to start but if you were to go
during the comedy time you don't have to
pay blink this slide so lady was like
shut the [ __ ] up Lisa Lisa Lisa and I
will go there with our our son tomorrow
her side and let they don't let kids in
there right so they would have to go eat
a table they didn't let kids on the
reservation Wow they would have to go in
there [ __ ]
TGI Fridays bro didn't [ __ ] jumbo
shrimp but one time she actually came
with me and bro bro it was nothing but
trailer trash masks in snacks and whites
and I would say they were all trailer
trash because they were some of them
were rockin that they were a good
looking bro yeah other chicks club we're
talking about all the cheese literally
Jaime Pressly bro with a bad forehead or
bad nose a chipped tooth but it was bad
and then and if you stood in long
another you realize the club turns into
a black lesbian bar it doesn't yeah they
would they'll hate us
if you don't know you Oh Tiffany took
her shoes off I was like oh god he loved
me we're gonna have to fight yeah and
she took her shoes off and jumped off
the stage and me and CC had that we're
like we're gonna have to fight these
girls cuz it was a little bit but the
guy went when they were doing the
electric slide he was so mad cuz he was
like these [ __ ] don't know who
I am and they were like they shuffle
into them it was so yeah be aggressive
in that room that everyone was so much
fun when I first started it was Fraser
doing it and then different Fraser it
went to Shane they went to Tiffany room
yeah but Tiffany was mad she that's the
first person I saw it really handled
well he was not afraid of them yeah yeah
and she made easy for anybody going up
to like you know my first time there it
was [ __ ] I'm pretty I was the name oh
yeah buddy yeah Fraser and John kept an
Arab wrong way back and bilk and that
guy bill Corso or the name is Oh does it
say Barry diamond every time
right and they were not first and I
won't have last but they're paying all
over the same bra and they actually had
a lot of food back there like nothing
such a bad ass time like a mad spray
then later I was Tiffany without
anything over into the food yeah they
gave us a voucher for like Chinese food
no it was crazy they would go Motel then
it kind of crowd like when they were
little for them having fun with throwing
rocks at the cars in a free way they
like breaking but like there's a they
like breaking bottles yeah cuz I did
that casino remember the casino bred
Ernst his ex-girlfriend use that was a
badass rule that paid yeah but the hotel
those better than they ever so tried to
sell me meth and I said no and then they
tried to sell it to my kids my son well
I brought this the same gig and I'm so
Bobo right so Baba yeah my brother I'm
Lisa and about the Sun and we're all
hanging out at Edwards room any this
food cut his foot on the floor on the
bed frame he could his foot yeah but
there's a better buffet though man the
buffet was good for that chicken and
waffles yeah they were shut you up in
that crowd you would say somebody was a
hold on baby hold on hold on baby hold
on and she waved her friend down to or
over here and okay baby we can go wow if
they like you they liked you what they
liked you bro what's off what the amiga
podcast again bro Perigord no activity
another feeling like really coming
Tuesday November 19 more aware bro
lacunae and that's at the Paramount in
Boyle Heights off of Cesar Chavez and
that's 8:00 p.m. on November 20th with
you know what Raza himself the host of
the yo-yo podcast Martine Moreno what's
up fool he's willing people to go to a
show in Baltimore man hit up any beauty
salon and just stay there man and just
talk every I really get although lately
a flyer and they'll pass a mile man for
you so that's what I do I go to barber
shops bro before like
couselor so I will go to a barbershop
leave my DVD a poster fight ticket for
the owner and in the other game and do
me a favor man when people are sitting
down waiting for a haircut another like
watching cartoons you play my [ __ ]
marketing I will tell about the play my
DVD bro and I will do that too although
all a barber shops in Ontario have my
DVDs huh and tattoo parlors to play with
DVD only so ever lasted a lot of state
down time people are waiting and just
like at least 25 people waiting every
hour [ __ ] my DVD plays all day and
these people it'll be my fans and they
show up to a show bro huh it's a host of
bro but somebody gotta do it really
smart now I'm gonna do it I learned
after that [ __ ] from the game all right
when the game had his arm his [ __ ] TV
show the promoter came out to him
because how we're gonna promote this man
listen man I don't know how they each of
promoting you but we're gonna promote
you the way you just promoting people
we're gonna put them up put your post to
every strip bar every every every rib
shop every nail salon every barber shop
from here so for 25 miles we truck I
mean Canepa lettuce there you go cuz you
know the club I gotta do it bro they
expect you go to the clubs each other
man yeah yeah promote my show and you go
to their page they got a 300
[ __ ] bro
and it's super morning a guy from last
two weeks ago we got [ __ ] Brian's
before likes is to our breasts galore
performer in there bro that's the truth
nothing against him but this you're
promoting him they're like they're
they're gonna put you on their social
media and then you doing them a favor
when you put them on your social media
and I'm gonna point then that we're
gonna do the [ __ ] up stop though and
then their own podcast ish ish yeah
doing the car what's up fool thank you
very much
hey Rodriguez anytime mom or other
[ __ ] yes no related
Eric Rivera
Maria Torres Lisa over there on the
couch the captain couch
Emma was a cheerleader come billing to
not doing the work of ten what self pool
thank you very much awesome